das
problem momentan das isses
remo hat sich vor drei jahren
das ist südkreis todesurteil mehr anders
nur vor 28 jahren und michell sich als
junge frau infiziert hat damals ist das
elend und
krieg in der medizin hat sich für die
geschlechtskrankheit vieles die
delitzscher jahrzehnt der emo übrigens
informiert michael curtiz normales leben
führen wie sie vorschläge und vorteile
sind aber immer noch verbreitet warum
werde ich gefragt für mich ist es die
rechte schulter gesehen wohl die gäste
in ausnahmen gibt es unanständig das ist
ja eigentlich volk wie heißt die
absteckt es stickig steuerlich spürbar
viel zu wenig informiert und
verbraucheraufklärung und wissen nicht
so recht was es heutzutage bietet zur
mit hiv leben
in der reportage begleitet zwei menschen
die ihre diagnose mit 25 jahre abstand
und mit komplett unterschiedlichen
perspektiven hand
[Musik]
das wird das spezielle reportage für
mich stehen jetzt vor der wohnung von
robotern von mir wo mir vor 2 offiziell
tsv positiv ist und mir handschuh
unser leuchtturm darüber geht über seine
geschichte und ich folgte mit mir wird
ja über das rheder über das stigma oder
die diskriminierung ohne mit hiv hat
sogar noch erlaubt dieses schweiz lautet
aktuell 17 musik menschen mit hiv 21
prozent der fonds in die therapie remo
scheine davor
ich muss ich muss eine reportage über
die spree hat damit
ihre letzte
show familie habe ich dir im oktober
bereit wäre die reportage metzmacher er
ist aber emotional nicht barock sie
öffentlich über seine diagnose treten
vor allem auch weil es gewissen lüthis
im unfalls nord welle persönlich sache
vorher ungeküsst hat wie sie werden
reagieren ja es ist oftmals auch jetzt
soll ein mitleid dort zum vorfall nach
so okay aber
auch völlig okay aber dass ich
wenn du diagnose politisches
instrumenten schock aber was viele nicht
wissen ist dass das problem eigentlich
nehme sehr groß ist es ist wirklich sehr
handelbar und haben es beschränkt sich
halt mit sachsengold ihr glück nun auf
die 1 die tabletten pro tag
das ist neue mitte juni bevor herr
vormonat erst seit nur noch zwei
wirkstoff darin dass man die wahrheit
vier wirkstoff kann
also das ganze hiv beschränkt sich
darauf dass du dir tablette nimmt das
ist so ja also das ganze zu sichern das
problem noch momentan das ich dass es
diese gibt sie mir live jetzt ein
geologe dies vorbei
denkt ihr aus hoffentlich mehrere also
spannend das lied wo
erfolgreiche halver therapie macht
eigentlich höhere lebenserwartungen dass
der durchschnitt vor die bevölkerung
über regelmäßige checks kommen um das
alte männer in bludesch gemacht und der
da weißt du halt immer ob du fit bist
über alles stimmten komplott wert mit
ihnen organ und rumhängt und reifer
therapie eine höhere lebenserwartung
wechsel steht also du dich das
medikament die nächsten 50 jahre walter
nettig nehme an es werde dort nach
öffentlicher bereich kiel ist
das und kraft da sind kann ich die
therapie starten
dass heuwer positive wo sich hüten dax
investiert sogar eine höhere
lebenserwartung als der durchschnitt hat
dem regus im arzt verzehrstudie dazu
gibt es aber nicht weiter hat sich immer
solche therapie möglichkeiten geirrt sie
zum beispiel der 1
und ich haben es
nach videobeitrag und auch hobbys vor
der zieht vor der therapie möglichkeiten
das ist also die zitrone in zerf in
innsbruck sie und ich anbieter gefunden
wo mich extrem berührt hat
wie hilft man menschen für die es keine
heilung gibt
ab mitte der 80er jahre stürzte die
krankheit aids auch die schweiz in
dieses dilemma aids kranke menschen
wurden damals einzig im sterbehospiz
lighthouse in basel betreut gepflegt und
auf ihrem letzten weg begleitet
in geschütztem rahmen konnte eine
schicksalsgemeinschaft trost und schutz
finden vor den misstrauischen blicken
der überforderten gesellschaft
kann jetzt de bietet ein dritter mann
und ich haben immer noch so ganz gut
wenn ich daran denke dass
luzern heran vor der gesellschaft punkt
wurde sind vorne und wir haben
extrem froh dass das für nötig ist dass
leute durch therapie ist normales leben
führen
und ja der vhs und ungeheuer sind
aber wie ist das früher maxi zum tausch
user findet treffe ich mich mit
hiv diagnosen in 200 jahren ins gewicht
dass ihre damalige mal das virus ist
sich breit doch der kinderwunsch vom
junge paar ist so groß dass michael das
risiko für ungeschützten
geschlechtsverkehr gegangen ist er ist
wenig später ausgestorben sich mit der
krankheit zu leben scheinen darüber rede
wie im
interview die diagnose bei orange
das ist ja
jeder mensch weiß ob
es sich damals nur das todesurteil sie
eigentlich
diagnose
tagen nochmals spontan an bord
projekt als tatort ähnliches hinzu
verdammt ich
bin in dem moment angriff stärker im
internet sehe und das nicht geboren sind
und das ist wie ein
fass voll voll akzeptiert dass du jetzt
wir sterben ja eigentlich so wäre es für
mich dass ja also ich bin endlich
authentisch wird nichts war schon in 30
oder sich eine 35
akku um diagnose kann ich mich engagiert
und hat kontakt gesucht sondern eine
positive und treffen gegangen
workshop geleitet
und damit sprache der relativ früh
menschen starben
also
so
plakativ zeit ist wirklich eine lüge
also wenn ich sehe dass die prämien oder
damals ist
dabei und
das baujahr später schon dann die
therapie
produktivität oder gehört erstmaligen
weder news hält werde therapiert also
mich damals sehr
skeptisch sehe
ich meine dass
sie mit heftigsten
aber immer noch und sie
leben der bürger wie sich das weiter
entwickelt und will ich so einfach so
form sicher war möglichkeit gesehen oder
ich habe ja wie abgeschlossen
also ich ja eigentlich nur meine
gegenwart und vergangenheit kalkar 25
und den plätzen größten etat zukunft
teuer was machen jetzt gedanken
im jahr 1901 also vor 20 jahren hat
michel mit der therapie opfer nachdem
sich ihre blutwerte drastisch
verschlechtern
medikament hat damals noch stark in aber
wirkliche karl proyer brache müdigkeit
und schlafstörungen
im gegensatz zu hüten damit wirklich
gefordert therapie re monierte er hat
sich wahrscheinlich am anfang von der
bezirks im x5 steckt die diagnose ist
für ihn überraschend rob dem schockiert
die sehr schmal und hat jetzt einen
filter gelder also etwa eine firma hat
ob ich wirklich dem zustand vor fakt ich
halte mein körper in ein wo mit
potenziellen umbringen und und er stehen
konnte und den verzerrte art dass die
tablette muss schnee und das ist das
problem ist und hast du jemand micha
steg kannst du sogar noch hinter all die
sachen die die verzählt der den macher
aber der erste moment ist schock wir
sind halt so wir sind halt so ja sie
sollte es großes thema unserer kindheit
oder
nein es geht und ins kino sind menschen
gestorben als die älteren immer gesagt
wie schlimm dass das ist in den news
hartwich leben dass das ist auch eine
kunst die diagnose über aber vor der
diagnose also
als studentischer kvist das eignet so
schlimm ist dass wir zu doktor ja ich
hatte eigentlich schon noch nicht gewiss
kraft also das heißt es todesurteil
nicht
problematisch wird der häufig dann wenn
man es nicht weiß und dumm mit
medikamentös therapiert wird einfach
durchs hiv virus zu sprechen und das
kann tödlich enden dass das thema aids
schöner krasses filter sind immer
verwechselt und so aber ja davon merkt
der vorbereitung wieder über geld und so
dass jedes auge oft passiert
bitte beachten dass nicht
sie will ich das auch skoda leicht ich
links die abwehr besser und h2o für mich
oder also wir so hämisch form dafür für
aids ist
erkrankt ist das andere krankheiten
bekämpfen also wenn das immunsystem so
launisch dass es nicht mal mehr
klassen oder damit irgendwie mit der
einfachsten sachen immer
viel zu wenig informiert und viel
luft klaric und wissen nicht so recht
was es heutzutage berichte zum mit hiv
leben und darum würde
angstreaktion ihr verurteilen weil das
ist halt so es ist
es macht angst
die bilder wo man hat wo wir hiv vor 20
jahren ist sie dass die bilder einfach
plötzlich verschwindet die sind halt da
ich zeige dir missionen sf archivbild
aus dem jahr 1986 es ist einfach auf die
straße zeigt wie wenig blut vor der
küste
des roten trikots
für
übertreibt wert und das habe ich gesagt
habe
die gesellschaft geht davon befallen
homosexuelle
und dann
einige bodenseeraum
warum glauben sie hat gerade der gruppe
erwischt
ja sagt schmid getraut dann dazu also
mit einer
tour de france vor der st
und was da nicht alle
brauchen
aber
das ist natürlich
wenn es der straße und von den 86
was vor den wellen stieg bei twitter
also das ist das eben um risikogruppe
oder randgruppe trifft das deb team und
jetzt also nur war unanständig klappt
oder bei uns afrika und trank ist
homosexuell wie genial und menschen mit
migrationshintergrund
also wo sich im
2020 gesteckt
wird jeder ecke drängt ja wir sind mit
schuld volk und schult zum tier nicht
bis es reflektiere bestehende gesetz
stelle wenn das team die andere und die
andere sind die fremde und die fremde
sind die autonomen sprache also ist ganz
verknappt gesagt oder durch mein
normalität ist sexuell wies und gesund
und so war fertig
traumberuf war nicht klar zu
sagen war damit entspricht
das sind die andere und bekommen dann
kommt es wirklich einfach sich hierbei
um
[Musik]
will man mit hiv liter norm entspricht
konnten sie die schweiz im jahr 2020
immer wieder zu diskriminierungen lud
der aids hilfe schweiz vor allem im
zusammenhang mit vorsichtiger und im
gesundheitswesen der emo hat sagt
wiemann vertreter von der krankenkasse
abgelegt hat und der hörer abhängt nach
dem vorsingen hiv-erkrankung erzählt hat
wahrscheinlich in dem therapie frühstück
remo findet das zwar den arbeit hat aber
mit zum morgen wie wichtig ist humor
der ganze thematik
sehr wichtig ein guter witz von hiv/aids
kugel und ich glaube du bist jetzt kunde
hat ist
positiv durch glaube also richtig lustig
war positive sich sehr sehr froh bin ich
am letzten umfrage macht auf instagram
nach mini-bar burgfried
obliegt mit hiv hütten oder
diskriminiert werden sondern nicht was
sie denkt und sagt prozent meint ja hit
werden positive immer noch diskriminiert
was ja da ist ja also ich hätte jetzt
das anders
gesagt dass grundsätzlich
sehr viel verständnis da ich aber es
braucht sehr viel wird die kommunikation
da ist andere clevere
hiv-positive
dann ist stieg man sowieso das sind
homosexuelle männer
junkies oder lied wo einfach
ungeschützten sex and
rush verlauf dass das auch klappt das
lied wird das mega ausschweifend klappt
oder sucht jemand wüsste die wegen der
bis ihnen drängen oder sage hey du bist
wirklich selber schuld oder wie
deutschland das gemacht
also dass ich es probleme allgemeines
problem weil diese gesellschaft ist
schubladisieren immer grad sofort also
eine halbseitige lähmung wegnehmen und
irgendwas ipod und blöd oder weiß nicht
was porsche sind
sicher dass noch immer tief
irgendwie der welt zurecht
von dem her also die so die verteidiger
überhaupt nicht ernst nehmen aber das
wie auch sein sohn james vor dem
ex-freund das ganze sache aha darum ja
genau
also ich meine sichern überzeichnet
gelockt das ist für meine
brasilianischen ex hypo habe oder dass
ich so biologie setzen so passiere sei
es gibt so viel geht wo es auf ganz
andere wege woche
beschlossen über zehn jahre dann eine
zweite halbjahr dp ck
nach der diagnose nach der diagnose
am renault sind ex partner heißt sei wie
unterschied zwischen zuvor wie
die beiden videos
können sie freundschaftlich miteinander
um zum zeitpunkt wo der emo aber
erfahren hat also wahrscheinlich wie hiv
positiv ist es für ihn ziemlich
krass
am besten man
macht
übrigens ähnliche therapie wieder remo
und datum auch mit nur minimalem
schranke rannten sich die beiden zwei
jahre nach der diagnose muss man andere
grund
remo data twitter aktuell trifft er sich
mit frauen um macht traurig dass
heterosexuelle frauen weniger gut
aufgeklärt sind als homosexuelle männer
er merkt immer wieder dass ansturm sind
michael hat nach ihrer diagnose und dem
tod von partner wie der orkan lübstorf
meinen wenn ihr partner oder partnerin
fcb das ist ein relativ langsam
schwierig sie
dies natürlich
hsg es geht einfach gar richtige
zeitpunkt zum theater also mein da geht
es nicht oder relativ langen jetzt
einfach nur zwei varianten sind
volkshilfe und
die anderen gefunden da kann ich sehe
jetzt quasi tot schlager du gehörst mir
also jetzt völlig übertrieben formuliert
so das
unternehmen
es war
wie so
oft märkte also wenn sie den handwerker
tv-kabel habe ich muss ja jeder jeden
dann blüht dann aber immer
integrieren interpretiert wieder
angesteckt oder bestraft als freundlich
sei verständlich und hier was ich alles
klappt und was ihre sexualität und aids
ohne die flüge zwischen dem takt auto
heroin oder keins von beidem friedlich
oder mal drauf gesehen also wer
eigentlich herr jetzt noch vier business
oder und warum wird ich fragte mich ist
er ist schuldig ist unschuldig gesehen
aus ständiges unanständig das ist ja
eigentlich volk wie heißt die absteckt
und das ist so immer und immer wieder
kolo geschah
des toten jemals eine bluthochdruck
ausstoß und seite hat mir jetzt als aber
mit bluthochdruck
wieso missionierung snow alte also wir
haben ja immer noch nur mit war uns in
effekte zu stecken oder und alte aber es
ist nicht einfach nochmal und
bedient man das nicht normal sie durch
something als das ist normal ein anderes
volk immer schwierig ist
die sieht im jahr 2000 auch wirklich
nimmer aus steckby und hat mit zwei
erwachsene sind wobei die kv hat was sie
mir erzählt hat habe mich berührt ich
zeige ihm remo wo übrigens mit meeres
büro teilt im schnitt im gespräch mit
der mission
funktion als
direktor je früher desto besser
ist das auch ein schwieriger moment ist
da ist mal wieder ganz anders sieht es
aber im
moment wo ich lebe was sie braucht gott
beasley aber wo man den arbeiter
gefangen im normalfall es geht doch erst
das nicht so ins lipper so alle übrigen
sich als tattoo arminia am unterarm oder
sowas ist im s korn es ist
also können wir vielleicht so dass wir
es forciert witzelte
hiv-positiv sie im 20 220
kreis
gesundheitsprobleme sondern es
angstproblem niveau falsch mit der angst
diskriminierend stück mutig anders
behandelt
allgemein drachen machen
das ist hier zu tag die negativ aus
welcher positiv und es ist kein
gesundheitskrise der schweiz vorliegt wo
in behandlung
drama in
wirklichkeit kein grund zum angst das
drama passiert alles der oper jetzt
normal dass man jetzt doch sie haben
einmal bestärkt darin dass eigentlich ja
das alles fragt vom vom umgang ist mit
dem mit
mit der krankheit
aber was hat euch gedanken zu dem thema
haben wir zum beispiel gewusst dass wenn
wir ihnen erfolge hiv-therapie schieben
immer ansteckbare schiebt man das doch
ohne kommentar und auch trotz der
therapiemöglichkeit vorhand liebt es
wichtig dass man sich bei risiko kontakt
schützt und testet und wenn ja wie
trainer zu dem man lasse werde ich den
link unter dem video die natur und wenn
es um fragen hand konnte noch nicht
gesehen wieder auf die frage egal und
vergesst nicht der kanal zu abonnieren